greetings a piece of Salam alaikum how
you guys doing
I'm with the old friend someone who get
the chance to catch up with [ __ ]
guess who sad to sleep how are you what
a cones I'm like them I'm good I'm good
how are you long time no see it's good
to finally catch up with you again it's
always pleasure to run into old friends
new friends and continuing the work you
know you doing some wonderful work out
there and we wanted to kind of go over
some because you actually we talked
about your journey the last program I
think it was actually had your brother
on the show - so you're somebody who can
relate to the climate the current
climate the whole climate all this all
the things that are going on you came
from if you haven't saw the show that I
did with him it was from punk rock to
Islam summary of that real quick and you
can see I will put it down in the
description to actually watch that show
but in summarizing what was the
uniqueness of your story Punk practice
them I know has gotten a lot of
attention but really is just about you
know the purpose of my life and finding
purpose in my life and
music was a big part of my life so it
kind of is a transition from music being
everything to really looking for
spirituality and meaning beyond just the
day-to-day or just you know trying to
have just trying to increase more fun a
lot of people live their life in that
way where their purpose of life and I
know it sounds shallow people won't
really admit that but a lot of times our
life just becomes about trying to
maximize fun you know and that's it and
then what happens when you reach the end
of your life like what does that like
been about so that was really my journey
which I think I'm still on this journey
and I think all Muslims were on this
continuous journey to get closer to
Allah to our Creator and to really live
for that higher purpose I had a brother
who reached out not too long ago and
that's gonna lead into my next question
he was someone who accepted Islam
Hispanic brother and he said Eddie he
said when I was hanging out with the
brothers with you guys I was on a
different level I kind of drifted off he
turned towards drugs he went away from
the Deen and how what kind of advice I
mean one thing is getting burned out the
essay and then you can see the
ramifications of what happens on one end
your practicing the Deen and you're on a
different level you we all got ups and
downs it happens that's life but then we
see what happens things don't get better
when you start going away from the
creator from Allah things as in this
example things just get far worse so how
can you prevent something like that
happening from a getting burnt out and
at the same time when you start getting
tempted Shaitaan is like come over here
it's like the grass is greener on the
other side and then you go and sometimes
you don't come back yeah look I mean
that's it that's a common issue right
I'm glad you brought it up because
people don't really talk about this you
know the whole burnout effect where you
know when a person first accepts it's
them when they first start practicing
with them
what happens is there's a rush of email
or somebody's been living their life
away from their 5th our pizza is our
natural inclination to where it's
goodness into where spirituality towards
Allah and then you know you live a whole
life like that and then finally you take
your Shahada you you you know you excuse
admit to a lot and it feels amazing
because now your soul is finally clicks
in and we're flooded with Iman which is
great and that knows in those beginning
days and months you know we need that
Russia be men to deal with all the
changes that were going through but the
problem is when you know we're doing
everything in 110 percent and we look at
you know sometimes there's this notion
of you know we look at different issues
and we all we just automatically feel
that maybe though the most difficult
opinion has to be the most correct and
when we do that and we do that for a
while and we're just that's that's it
now our life just becomes you know that
one track and we don't find about and we
don't lead a balanced life it can be
too much for us and then as you said you
know the ship on doesn't take you from
there to hey let's find some balance the
ship on takes you from there too you
know what it may be this whole thing is
wrong maybe this whole religion things
not for you maybe this whole town thing
is not for you and actually interesting
enough and I'm if I even looked out it
actually talked about this phenomenon he
talked about how the ship on he's happy
in two scenarios when Allah commands
something the ship on will take one of
two stances either excessiveness going
too far doing too much because he knows
that of a reason of burnout is gonna be
too much but when that burnout happens
initially I thought the other thing he
will pull towards if not excessiveness
it's negligence and shortcoming so
that's why that's that's the pull so
initially there's a pull of you know
what just go out just do just do
everything you know as much as you can
on this now that that's all our life is
about and then the next pull is oh you
know what you're not finding that
satisfaction you're not finding that
peace and then we go to the other end
which is leaving it all together and the
problem is this the most apparent to a
de has created us with needs our biggest
and most important need is our spiritual
need I need to worship a lot that need
to be spiritual beings but it doesn't
mean that we don't have other needs for
example we have the need to be social
beings we have the need and lot of you
know religious people don't like this to
hear this but we have the need to have
fun and to relax to rest to have a good
time
but within obviously the parameters of
them but if we completely cut out that
need and we don't make time for that
then we're not fulfilling that need at
any time you don't fulfill a need
eventually the nufs begins to feel it
just like you know our spiritual needs
if we never fulfill them we're just
living dunya dunya dunya dunya that's it
then I mentioned our soul is gonna be
like something's wrong we need to
fulfill that need
likewise if our life becomes only about
hey I just got a worship worship and
this not like that's it and there's no
room for the dunya then our nuts feels
that as well and that's why the person
sending them in his Sunda we find
examples of this we know those through
three people who came press the send
them came to his house came to ask about
his worship and you know they ask is
nari but unasur they left that I knew
who was the companion who would you know
serve I said I mean he knew her Saddam's
life inside out so they asked him about
Merced was worship and these three guys
they honest is like you know they
weren't really impressed by the person
he said no kind of luck so one of them
he says you know okay well you know
percenter he's had his past and future
sins forgiven we're not at that level so
we need to do more this is what they're
trying to say so one of them he says I
am gonna fast every single day another
one he says I am going to pray the whole
night another person he says I'm never
going to get married
another person hears about this and he
calls them back and he says did you make
these statements they said yes they says
well I India ash are coming in now
that's coffee and I says I swear by
Allah I have the most piety amongst all
of you but I'm your example yet I fast
and I don't fast I don't fast every
single day and I pray and I sleep and I
get married so here and then he said man
about ensign Latif and they submitted me
the one who goes outside of my son
that's something beyond my Sunnah and
they're not from me I mean you can take
a look at all these issues and be like
hey what's wrong here people says what's
wrong with fasting what's wrong with
praying right but the issue is when it
goes into an extreme that goes outside
of the similar pressures in them it goes
in tuning that that takes us beyond what
Allah knows is best for us and that's
why our spirituality begins and ends
with what the per centum is taught us
you know sometimes people seek
spirituality outside of the some another
synonym they want to do things the
president didn't do and then they're
like you know it's good though right
I know person time didn't do it like
this or you didn't do this but I'm not
doing something which is bad well the
problem is one of the dangers is that
when we go outside of the similar
pressure center we can get to a place
where we go into an extreme we can
overwhelm ourselves and like I said from
that point the chiffons not like hey
calm down calm down a little bit
he's like I just leave it all together
right and that's that's really so I'm
really glad you brought this up that's
that's the danger so it is important
that we balance our lives and we find
that balance and that balance and you
said how can we deal with that well one
of the most important things is
knowledge educating ourselves when we
understand the Sun another precious item
we understand how he led his life we
begin to see what a balanced life looked
like did the precious item have fun and
joke and laugh yes did he how was he
with his family did he have rest and
relaxation time with his family and now
all of that is part of the similar his
behavior how is his character was with
people you know how did he deal with
people who are overtly or overtly sinful
was he on their case in like pop no we
have beautiful examples we have that one
one guy young person comes the press
sedative he says o Messenger of Allah
make it head-on for me to commit zina to
have sex outside of marriage
if it was one of us we would have seen
them but like the stuffings
get out of my face you're asking me to
say that it's okay to commit zina have
sex outside of marriage
what rested I'm doing he spoke to him
with the best of character and he said
would you like that would you like that
somebody commit sin and one of your
female relatives and this young man he
says no I wouldn't like that I don't
want to one want somebody to commit sin
oh and one of my female says he said
president said likewise when you commit
sin oh you'll be committing zina with
someone's relative that's a human being
right that's it that's a that that woman
is is you know related to somebody and
so now he understands right so if I
spoke to him on his level with this
beautiful character that's where we find
this balance we found that balance in
the life of our sin demand that comes
with educating ourselves keeping a
balance as he was talking about soul and
4/10 and we see what happens when you go
away on the submission to the Creator
not the creation Islam start to drift
off hold on hold tight don't get burnt
out keep a healthy balance tell us [ __ ]
and by the way if you didn't know your
first time listening to our brother he
went from punk rock to a slob to Medina
and he started studying learning this
Deen and now he's out there helping to
share this message message of peace
peace of choir by submission to the will
of God living purpose sharing purpose
but then there's out there look there's
people you know when you're not getting
powered by this Deen you're getting
powered by everything else you think
superficial materialistic and then
you're Muslim by name right you get
emotional like when the balloon is
filled up with hot air you just you
don't know how to intellectually tackle
many of these things and you're on the
social media and then you see someone
that you really admired for example
famous game show host there's people
like this you ignore a lot of the troll
but then someone who has a big following
for instance says something like what
I'm gonna repeat maybe he has really or
has never walked into a mosque sat with
a Muslim so we have a great opportunity
now for you to go ahead and communicate
a message to this person but also how
should you deal with this because you
see a lot of Muslims not cursing
swearing acting opposite to the Sunnah
and the way of good character and
manners
so when you see game show host Chuck
Woolery and then someone like this
offending over 1.6 billion Muslims in a
statement if you don't by saying if you
don't know Islam is evil then you don't
know history and you refuse to reason
I'm not saying every Muslim is evil
different how would you what message
would you have to him and what advice
would you have Muslims who are really
hurt by hearing something like this
and I'm really glad you brought this up
look I I completely understand when we
hear these types of things and famous
people are well known people sounds evil
sounds bad and we hear for example
somebody on Fox News ranting about how
Islam is the root of terrorism and all
this kind of stuff it's easy to start to
feel overwhelmed
it's easy to feel like you know what I
just can't make a difference you know
what no matter what I say you know this
is how people are gonna be with them and
you know what voice do I have you know
when somebody on TV is saying they're
somebody famous comes out and shows like
this this either hatred for Islam or or
shows this incorrect representation it's
them it's easy to want to lose hope and
by the way losing hope is one of the
goals of the shift on for us he wants us
to lose hope he wants us to be like you
know what we can't do anything you know
it's just that we cannot there's nothing
we can do but remembers kind of lock
that in the end of the day the law is
the one who protects this team Allah is
one who preserves this Deen no matter
what people say in the end of the day of
law is in charge a lot is in control no
matter what people say that's number one
number two look the most powerful thing
out there more powerful than someone
famous saying something something being
said on Fox News
even you know president like Donald
Trump saying something more powerful now
is you and your connection with a real
human being so when we sit and talk to
someone they can have and I've been in
situations like this speaking to someone
who has all of the misconceptions all of
the stereotypes about us now you know
they think it's not as evil or Liz and
that and terrorism and all of long list
of things but when you sit down with
this person and you communicate with
them and they see what a Muslim looks
like and they hear what a Muslim
believes from the mouth of a Muslim that
is more powerful than anything that
happens on TV or in social media and all
of that and that's why that's our job
these days that's what we focus on is
speaking to our or our neighbors
co-workers of people's oh I'm not saying
hey you've got to preach to everybody
that's not what I'm saying I'm saying is
talk to them let them see what a what a
Muslim looks like and what our what our
beliefs are what we really believe and I
believe I honestly believe and once we
once a once someone like that actually
meets a real Muslim and they start
spending time with Muslims all this
other stuff will better
and we need to have that confidence
number one in Islam and number two in
our own selves as representatives of
them now as if famous game show host
Chuck Woolery
he was live enemy let me sit with these
guy I want to sit he he he was like I
want to meet some of these these Muslims
we've been talking to me from the Deen
show would you be willing and what
message would you have directly to Chuck
okay first of all if you said what
message will have for Chuck if he's
hearing this I would say go speak to a
realist and ask them and speak to them
about what their beliefs are and that
would be my message to him if I'm
speaking to everybody else I would say
once again it is important to connect
with him on a real level as a human
being it's easy to get emotional it's an
easy to be to get aggressive with
somebody who's aggressive with you
almost peyote Allah says it defer bility
here accent repel evil with that which
is better someone curses us out it's
easy to curse them out someone says
those times evil
it's easy turn around say no you're a
bigot you're this you're that you're a
racist you don't know anything you're
just you know to have this view that
that they are evil we as Muslims we
don't look
we're we don't look at life in this
black-and-white way you're either evil
are good and that's it and everyone's
defined in their role and that's that
nobody can change how many people Eddie
how many people do you know who went
from hating Islam to not only liking us
them to becoming Muslim
if that's not proofed and I don't know
what is we don't we don't look at anyone
and say ah this person is that's it they
are enemy we looked at this person and
we say this person needs to be educated
they need to hear about the beauty of
Islam some did Allah we're coming to a
close I got one more thing I want to
touch upon you've been talking a lot a
bit about this also we touched upon it
behind the scenes we can bring it to
fruition now tell me you know that
there's there is you know the Prophet
peace and blessing be upon the last and
final message sent to mankind
who I always say he's the brother to
Jesus Moses Abraham they all brought
that same message of Islam submission to
the crater not the creation he said I
have not been sent acceptable to perfect
good manners character sometimes we'll
see you know there's the uniform of
Islam
modesty mimicking the best of women
Jesus's mother Mary and sometimes you'll
see people who are not in accordance
with the dress code or some people that
are but then their character is not in
line with with it or some people that
are but then you know you have someone
who will wear the the veil but
everything else you know is the jeans
showing and whatnot so how do you strike
a balance there you actually touch upon
this many people do just don't know if
and people have that sincere of heart
they're open they wanted to it's all
about changing making progress climbing
the spiritual ladder so I believe these
are the kind of things that you touch
upon in your classes what advice do you
have for new Muslims they're there you
know maybe she went from a really tawdry
dress maybe he's always wearing the
babyGap shirt everything is showing on
him - right but it's a complete package
with Islam but then there's some people
stuck they've been like 10 15 years
they're like it's all in my heart right
and Allah a great question and I'd say
this is a great question because I'm
actually good
I'm teaching a class on this home topic
and the topic of clothing and culture
and once again you know when we're
talking about extremism going all out or
nothing and unfortunately when it comes
to our clothing and our dress sometimes
we take that approach as well there's
those people who say it doesn't matter
what you wear right whatever the culture
says you wear you wear you know that's
one extreme the other extreme is know
you gotta wear this exact clothing you
gotta wear a thug for example right they
look at your brother Eddie to be like
who he's wearing as a tie he's wearing a
suit that's not Muslim clothing right
and that's the other extreme Islam gives
us general guidelines protecting our
modesty covering our outer dressing in a
dignified way but the exact thing of
what you have to wear Islam does say go
back to your culture as long as it
fulfills those conditions so it's
important and once again it's about
education it's about learning about what
Islam tells us about our dress and
clothing what does it mean to dress in a
dignified way what does that mean so
once again it's easy to get caught up in
one or the other like you said there's
people who are like oh all that matters
is what's in the heart you know Preston
I'm said that in the body there's a
morsel of flesh if it is sound the rest
of the body would be sound as well and
he said most certainly that is the heart
if said if it's ruined the rest of the
body will be ruined as well so in the
end of the day our exterior is a
reflection of our interior so if the
heart is trying to purify itself we
should try to purify our exterior as
well we should try and dress in the way
as
sandwiches Islamically the most
dignified right and it's not one or the
other it's not just the heart just the
outside we are in a constant struggle as
Muslims to purify our hearts and purify
our exterior as well that's why I look
even I'll worship our worship isn't
perfect does that mean we leave it all
together
oh we try our best and we continue to
try we continue to struggle we continue
to try to be better and closer to Allah
in our hearts and our exterior whether
it's our dress whether it's our behavior
whether it's our worship Allah didn't
make us perfect beings we're all
struggling the point is that we keep
struggling the point is that we keep
submitting submitting is not a one-time
deal Eddy you know this submitting is a
daily action it's a hourly action it's a
moment-to-moment action that we submit
right and the Shaitaan will come to you
and tell you hey what's the point you're
not perfect what's the point you don't
fit this category of that category and
it's easy to want to give up to lose
hope but what matters is that with that
we keep striving and keep struggling
keep educating ourselves and keep acting
upon that knowledge and ask the Lost
Planet Allah to give us all the strength
to persevere and to continue and to live
this life of submission to Allah spam
Tejada bringing us peace in our hearts
and our and honor in our lifestyle as
well Jesus did it Moses did it Abraham
did it the last and final messenger did
it lived his beautiful way of life
direct connection with the creator that
happens in earth Islam [ __ ] tell us how
can people hook up with you get in touch
with you you got a website you got a
Twitter what do you got so people can
connect with you and maybe Chuck Chuck
and also connect hey look I'll make it
easy for you any social media site you
can think of
I believe most meetings I'm on facebook
I'm on Twitter
I'm on Instagram I'm on snapchat just
look for Assad to Salim s aadt ASL p.m.
on Facebook Twitter Instagram snapchat
you can connect with me on there in
chocolate and I look forward to hearing
from you actually so if you're online
tweet at me and you know if your
Instagram whatever look forward to
hearing from you thank you very much so
is it an honor was a pleasure thank you
for being with us and the angel
responsibly use it responsibly the
social media tools every week Fridays we
release the new show God willing
inshallah connect with us subscribe if
you haven't already
Chuck get with us the message is coming
to you it's not a love Chuck we got love
for you and all of mankind Islam look
look look
Islam says love all of mankind that's
why we're delivering this message this
message of peace peace acquired by
submission to real God we'll see you
next time in Charlotte until then peace
moving something
[Applause]